Since her film debut in 1994, Scarlett Johansson
has become one of the most recognizable and
successful actors in Hollywood. Here are a few of
the most critically acclaimed roles that Johansson
has portrayed throughout her career, from
independent efforts to blockbuster smash hits.
Still Johansson's best-reviewed film on Rotten
Tomatoes, Lost in Translation was hailed as a
revelation upon its release in 2003, both for
its leading performance by Bill Murray and for
Sofia Coppola's stylish and elegant direction.
However, it's Johansson's performance that gives
the movie the profound sense of existential
loneliness that Coppola's films are known for.
Johansson plays Charlotte, a recent
college graduate visiting Japan.
Adrift in her life and uncertain about her
future, Charlotte befriends fading actor Bob,
played by Murray, who feels similarly lost as he
flounders through middle age. The two keep each
other company for a few days in Tokyo, forming a
deep bond over their mutual sense of alienation.
The film landed Oscar nominations for Best
Picture, Best Director and Screenplay for Coppola,
and Best Actor for Murray, although Johansson
was unfortunately snubbed. Regardless,
Lost in Translation was declared
an instant classic by many critics.
Terry Lawson of The Detroit Press
summed up the general appeal, writing,
"There is real magic afoot in Lost in
Translation — the sort that is created
not at the wave of a wizard's wand, but by
the coming together of two wayward souls."
Although Johansson didn't get much screen time
in Avengers: Infinity War, her iconic portrayal
of the MCU's Natasha Romanoff, otherwise known
as Black Widow, played a pivotal role in the
grand cinematic finale that was Avengers:
Endgame. As one of the few Avengers left
standing after the Snap, Johansson plays
a hero worn down by loss and despair.
Endgame provides Black Widow with an emotional
sendoff, as she — spoiler alert — sacrifices
herself to help save the world. However, the
cosmic dust had barely settled on Endgame
before Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige announced
a Black Widow standalone movie in July 2019.
It may have taken nine years since the first
Avengers movie for Johansson to get her own film,
but it's certainly better late than never
for her legions of fans. Although the movie
was delayed multiple times, Black Widow is
currently slated to hit theaters in July 2021.
While Johansson is primarily known for
her live action work, she has also lent
her voice to a number of prominent films,
including The Jungle Book, Isle of Dogs,
and The SpongeBob SquarePants Movie. However, her
most acclaimed voiceover work to date was her role
as an artificially intelligent operating system
in Her, written and directed by Spike Jonze.
The near-future sci-fi film, which won an Oscar
for Jonze's original screenplay, chronicles the
romantic misadventures of sad-sack writer Theodore
Twombly, played by Joaquin Phoenix, who finds
himself falling in love with the artificially
intelligent virtual assistant "Samantha."
It's easy to see why Theodore falls for Samantha,
even though she has no physical form. Samantha's
soulful personality, humor, empathy, curiosity,
and intelligence can all be felt through
Johansson's voice alone. Samantha also conveys a
certain wistfulness about the experience of living
that feels all too human, despite her artificial
nature. Critics were charmed and dazzled by
Jonze's vision, with Empire magazine declaring,
"Jonze has made a sweet, smart, silly, serious
film for our times, only set in the future."
Alongside Taika Waititi's Jojo Rabbit,
Johansson earned one of her first two
Oscar nominations in 2019 for Noah Baumbach's
Marriage Story. A searing portrayal of divorce,
Marriage Story sees Johansson play Nicole,
a former teen star married to Charlie,
a theater director played by fellow Oscar
nominee Adam Driver. When Nicole wants
to move to Los Angeles to advance her career
even though Charlie wants to stay in New York,
their already troubled union begins
to slide towards dissolution.
Baumbach himself has said that
the film is semi-autobiographical,
partially based on his divorce
from actor Jennifer Jason Leigh.
While Baumbach's sympathies are clearly biased
in Charlie's favor, Johansson still brings an
enormous amount of sympathy and relatability
to the character of Nicole. Critics gushed
about the film and the performances, with
Moira MacDonald of The Seattle Times raving,
"Johansson and Driver are remarkably,
heartbreakingly good in every scene."
Ghost World was an early critical success
for Johansson and an important transition
from her career as a child actor. Though
she was only sixteen upon its release,
the 2001 movie, co-written and directed by Terry
Zwigoff, is a mature and serious film about two
young women facing an uncertain world after
their high school graduation. For Johansson,
Ghost World — adapted from Daniel Clowes'
comic book series Eightball — was also her
first foray into a genre that would catapult her
into the highest ranks of international stardom.
The movie stars Thora Birch as Enid, a
classic Generation X archetype: ironic,
lost, and darkly cynical. Johansson
plays the role of her best friend,
Rebecca, who is slightly more tethered to reality,
and their difference in outlook eventually
leads the girls to having a falling-out.
"Some people are okay, but mostly I
just feel like poisoning everybody."
Ghost World was not very popular with audiences,
but it was widely praised by critics, who
appreciated its offbeat sense of humor,
emotional honesty, and unsparing depiction
of teenage angst. As Roger Ebert wrote,
"I wanted to hug this movie. It takes such
a risky journey and never steps wrong.
It creates specific, original,
believable, lovable characters,
and meanders with them through their inconsolable
days, never losing its sense of humor."
The culmination of Phase One of the MCU, The
Avengers proved that Marvel movies were here to
stay. The movie grossed more than 1.5 billion
dollars and was beloved by both audiences and
critics, with a certified fresh score of 91%
on the Tomatometer. With almost 25 minutes
of screentime, Johansson's Black Widow is the
third most prominent character in The Avengers,
after Iron Man and Captain America.
Even if her role in The Avengers isn't
as dramatically juicy as the one she gets
in Captain America: The Winter Soldier,
she still gets her fair share of heroic
moments, especially as the Avengers save
New York from Thor's brother Loki and his
legions of alien henchmen in the final act.
While critics lauded the movie's
action and special effects,
many were equally impressed by the performances
of the Avengers themselves. In his review of
the film for The Atlantic, Christopher Orr
wrote that Johansson's Black Widow is, quote,
"far more interesting than she was in
Iron Man 2," and that the cast in general
"[...] is excellent down the
line, and plays well together,
even — perhaps especially —
when their characters don't."
The 2014 Captain America sequel The Winter
Soldier was something of a welcome departure
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Phase 2 of the MCU had gotten off to
a bit of a rocky start with the successful but
uninspired Iron Man 3 and the middling Thor:
The Dark World. Both films had done well at the
box office, but it was clear the MCU needed a
fresh approach. The Winter Soldier delivered by
fusing its typical superhero fare with elements
of the spy thriller genre popularized by classic
films like The Parallax View and Three Days of
the Condor. Critics were impressed with
The Winter Soldier's action set pieces
and its topical narrative about the price of
freedom and "security" in the age of surveillance.
As Black Widow is the primary Avenger featured
alongside Captain America in the film,
Johansson benefited from the film's acclaim, and
was subsequently prominently featured in Avengers:
Age of Ultron. But while that film's
reputation may have faded over the years,
The Winter Soldier has emerged as an
MCU favorite, with Johansson providing
a big part of its continuing appeal among
both casual viewers and Marvel fanatics.
Johansson reunited with Iron Man 2 director
Jon Favreau for his 2014 passion project
about a middle-aged chef and his bold attempt to
reignite his creative spirit. Favreau plays the
titular chef, Carl Casper, and Johansson
is Molly, the hostess at the restaurant
Casper worked at for 10 years before his
very public mid-life crisis meltdown.
"You're not getting to me! You're not
getting to me! He's not getting to me!"
Favreau and Johansson have a
natural chemistry in this film,
stuffed with stars as it is with delectable
dishes, including Dustin Hoffman, Sofia Vergara,
and Robert Downey Jr. Johansson's Molly is just as
appealing as any of the cuisine on display, which
is no small feat in a movie guaranteed to have
you craving a gourmet meal from beginning to end.
Critics were mostly charmed by the light comedy
— which sits at 87% on the Tomatometer — praising
the cast, the soundtrack, and of
course, the delicious-looking food.
Writing in Little White Lies,
Chris Blohm called the movie
"A sassy and mouth-watering
concoction, bursting with flavour."
Given her comic abilities and previous experience
as a sultry femme fatale-type in post-war Los
Angeles in The Black Dahlia, Johansson was a
no-brainer to join George Clooney, Channing Tatum,
Ralph Fiennes, Frances McDormand, and
Tilda Swinton in the all-star cast of Hail,
Caesar!, a Coen Brothers comedy set in 1950s
Hollywood. Johansson plays DeeAnna Moran,
a character based off of actress Esther Williams,
who performs in synchronized swimming routines
that were popular at the time. When DeeAnna's
unplanned pregnancy threatens her career and
the studio's bottom line, a studio fixer played
by Josh Brolin is tasked with covering it up.
Although audiences had mixed
reactions, critics enjoyed the movie,
praising the Coen Brothers' playful spirit,
its performances, and its nostalgic reflection
on Hollywood's golden age. The Guardian's
Mark Kermode wrote of the film as a whole,
"It's utterly chaotic and ridiculously indulgent,
and it would amount to intolerable cruelty
were Hail, Caesar! not so consistently,
uproariously, affectionately funny."
Johansson has carved out a niche for herself
in the science fiction genre more than most of
her fellow A-list actors. In addition to
her many appearances in the MCU and Her,
the actor has also headlined Michael Bay's
The Island, the surprise global hit Lucy,
and the controversial live action remake of Ghost
in the Shell. But while Under the Skin is sci-fi,
this indie film has little else in common
with those big budget commercial affairs.
A product of guerrilla filmmaking, Under the
Skin surrounded Johansson with real people,
not actors, and captured much of its
unscripted footage with hidden cameras.
The movie is light on action in favor of a
detached, cerebral story about a feminine alien,
played by Johansson, who uses her good
looks to hunt down men throughout Scotland
and lure them back to her dark lair to consume
them. However, as soon as she appears to identify
more traditionally as a human woman, she
finds herself going from predator to prey.
Although a box office failure, Under the Skin
found favor with critics and scholars who
read it as a feminist allegory about gender
inequality. It also showed off Johansson's
continued desire to take on challenging and
cryptic roles outside of the usual blockbusters.
Taika Waititi won the Best Adapted Screenplay
Oscar for his anti-hate satire Jojo Rabbit,
which made waves upon its release for its unique
take on World War II. The film stars Roman Griffin
Davis as the titular Jojo, a young German boy
whose imaginary best friend is a caricature of
Adolf Hitler, played by Waititi himself. While the
film was marketed as a comedy, Johansson's role as
Jojo's mother Rosie serves as the emotional core
of the film, as she struggles to balance being a
single mother to a blindly nationalist child with
hiding a Jewish teenager from the Nazi forces.
Critics and audiences alike enjoyed
Jojo Rabbit, praising its humor,
charm, and anti-hate message. However, as with
many comic takes on Hitler and Nazis, Jojo Rabbit
generated its fair share of controversy,
with Joanne Laurier writing that the movie
"[...] inadvertently or not trivializes
Nazism and turns people away from a study
of the concrete historical processes
that produced such horrific carnage."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.